voilà nous entrons dans ce beau t2 la
pièce principale qui fait un peu plus de
20 mètres carrés y faire lumineux le
parquet récent première visite pour
jean-pierre il est intéressé par l'achat
de cet appartement de 53 mètres carrés
allées du parc avec des taux d'emprunt
de 1,2 pour cent en moyenne
c'est l'occasion pour lui de faire un
bon investissement de la vie c'est vrai
qu'on a eu à avoir des taux à 0,5 sur
dix ans au niveau de la banque
donc ça représente rien en plus on peut
louer quand même relativement facilement
quand on a des biens de bonne qualité un
faux pas acheter n'importe quoi non plus
donc c'est vraiment ce qui nous a
poussés et puis si un investissement
qu'il est tout à fait correct en rapport
qualité prix c'est moi je pense que ça
vaut le coup je passe devant vous ici
nous sommes dans la cuisine une bonne
affaire aussi pour cet agent immobilier
avec un coût du crédit moins cher
nombreux sont ceux à vouloir investir à
tel point que l'offre manque c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment donc de bien voilà il
faut aller chercher les biens là il va
falloir en rentrée on manque de biens
ça va peut-être encourager certaines
personnes à vendre beaucoup de jeunes
aujourd'hui cherchent à acheter plutôt
que payer des loyers mais la rareté des
biens peut-elle conduire à une
augmentation des prix pour ce courtier
cette tendance n'a pas encore d'impact
sur leur valeur pour l'instant ça reste
très stable
on n'a pas vraiment d'augmentation de la
valeur des biens immobiliers par contre
en effet on a de plus en plus
d'acquéreurs
on a vraiment des gens qui aujourd'hui
pas sûr pas grâce à ce taux bas pour
tout achat immobilier
ces experts conseille d'emprunter assez
faible taux qui ne bougeront pas sur le
long terme plutôt que de toucher à votre
est pas